afternoon so if you haven't gotten your
exams Esther has them right it's after
class you can get them you don't want to
take them now because you won't pay
attention to me so afterwards today
we're going to start talking about
infection of organisms not just cells so
we're going to look at some of the
principles of pathogenesis the rest of
the course we'll deal with this aspect
of how viruses infect you so we're going
to talk about infections in the real
world not in a culture dish and this
actually refers to part three of the
tripartite strategy which we talked
about way in the beginning and that is
all viral genomes are able to establish
themselves in a host population so that
the viruses can keep going on and on and
on and I would suggest that you have a
look at Appendix B in the textbook
Appendix B is in the volume - it's
called pathogenicity snapshots and it
gives you an overview of individual
viral diseases I'll be mentioning
various viral diseases from time to time
and it will help if you've got some
familiarity with them it's mostly a
visual appendix so I think that would be
very useful as outlines of the viruses
the epidemiology and the disease
mechanisms so some basic facts every
host today that's us and other animals
plants insects that are hosts for
viruses has intrinsic defenses and
immune defenses and we will talk about
how they differ later on that have
evolved to deal with infections viral
infections bacterial fungal all sorts as
well as tumors
and every virus has to counter those
defenses otherwise there wouldn't be any
viruses around we will talk a lot about
this modulation of host defenses this is
the interface of virus host interaction
it's a very interesting area of study
this is one of my favorite lines we live
in prosper in a literal cloud of viruses
if you could stain them you'd see them
floating around in the air here but as
we said before most infections are
inconsequential most of the particles
floating in this room which were left
from the previous class they will never
find a living cell to infect the land on
your skin which of course is dead and
they can't multiply them there they will
be inactivated by drying or ultraviolet
light not much here now but in the
summer there will be and none of them
get beyond one or two cells in the
initial side of infection if we do
happen to get infected and I'll bet
we're all infected on a daily basis
these little bursts of infection a few
cells here and there but we don't know
about it if we do get infected beyond
that we don't have symptoms many
infections are what we call in a parent
this is an important concept the vast
majority of most infections don't cause
any symptoms that you can recognize so
you think you're fine and there's
nothing happening but there really is
repres in these cases could be
replicating and being transmitted so
even though you don't feel ill you could
be transmitting virus to others it's
likely that you are in fact here's an
example West Nile virus infection West
Nile virus was not present in the US
before what year
don't remember somebody have a textbook
with them no I can't remember the year
but it came to the u.s. very late in the
late 90s perhaps dictate Pommier will
tell you all about this at the end of
the course by October 2004 not many
years after it was introduced by the way
it probably came from an airplane from
Israel but we're not sure about that
came to the US and in New York City
summer of October 2004 about 1 million
people were infected we know this
because they did Sara surveys for the
presence of antibodies only 20% of the
people had fever and only 1% of the
people had neuro invasion which is good
because when you get neuro invasion it's
not good
many people were infected with no
obvious disease with West Nile virus
during that period and they continue to
be and this leads to transmission
because you give blood and you don't
know you're infected if you give an
organ you can give someone virus because
they don't check organs for every
possible virus they probably should but
not yet and this it makes it hard to
stop an epidemic because you can't
recognize it early enough because people
are shedding viruses and they don't have
symptoms if you have symptoms you take
care of them but if you don't you
transmit the infection so two facts in a
paradox oil hosts have remarkable
defenses that block most viral
infections before they start this should
be clear by now we have lots of
infections and we are healthy because we
can take care of them but some
infections aren't stopped when you get
sick and many die of viral infections so
what happened to the defense system
where did they go and how can a virus
with a couple of genes even for the
smallest virus how can a virus make us
sick and kill us so that's these are
some of the questions we'll try to
answer in the rest of this course and
we'll be talking about viral pathogen
is's which and pathogenesis is the
process of producing a disease we talk
about viral pathogen is's it is produced
by a virus but it could be bacterial or
fungal or protozoan as well and viral
disease that is when you get sick with a
virus infection you have a viral disease
if you have symptoms it is a combination
of the effects of the virus replicating
in the host and the effects of the host
response on both the virus and yourself
so I want you to forget the idea that
the virus is doing everything to make
you sick you are contributing by immune
having an immune response against
the virus virus infections span from
benign which we've been talking about
non in apparent infections they go from
there to lethal
that's quite a range and everything in
between there can be acute infections
that are over very quickly and there can
be persistent infections that go on for
years and years and different mechanisms
are at play and we'll talk about some of
those a little history for many many
years of our existence we didn't
understand about microbes as infectious
agents we thought when we got sick it
was because the air was poisoned and we
breathed it in and it had toxins in it
and it made us sick and that's why they
were epidemics of contagious disease we
knew there were epidemics of disease and
that people spread it but we didn't know
anything about microbes that Association
didn't happen until the late 1800s when
Robert Koch said microorganisms which
had been brought to the world by Louis
Pasteur said these can cause disease and
he formulated his Koch's postulates to
identify the agent responsible for a
specific disease he coined the word a
pathogen and said microbes can be
pathogen so it's really not a very long
time that we have this understanding of
microbes as infectious agents but we
have learned a lot here is a wonderful
picture of three the main players in
yellow fever yellow fever virus was the
first human virus to be identified in
1901 and three of the major players in
this story were Carlos Finlay jesse
lazier and Walter Reed and they showed
that a virus was the cause of yellow
fever they're interested in this because
they're trying to build a canal through
Panama and mosquitoes were transmitting
disease to a lot of the workers so this
is a painting showing these three
gentlemen here and they've got a tube
full of mosquitoes and they are letting
them bite one of these individuals here
to show that you can transmit yellow
fever with a mosquito so this of course
was not an IRB approved
in fact the 1901 there was no IRB you
can't do this we use this is why we use
animals nowadays you can't experiment on
humans but in fact over the years many
scientists did experiment on themselves
some of the questions that we'll be
tackling for the rest of the course how
does a virus enter a host
well how does the host respond where
does the virus replicate at least
initially how does the virus spread what
what kinds of organs does it infect
doesn't always infect every organ and if
it doesn't why is the infection cleared
right away is it a quick or acute
infection or do you establish a
persistent infection that goes on for
years and years and finally how do you
transmit the infection to other hosts
it's not always the same for all viruses
to have a successful infection there are
a number of requirements have to have
enough viruses you have to be infected
with enough viruses and that differs
according to the virus in the particular
situation it may be a few particles it
may be a few million particles the cells
where the virus lands have to be
accessible they have to be susceptible
and permissive those two last two terms
of course you know we've talked about
those before but accessible Maryse has
to be able to reach them if it can't
there will be a successful infection the
the local antiviral defenses have to be
at least initially defective sometimes
absent entirely in order to allow the
virus to replicate so how do you get
enough viruses at the site of infections
how many viruses does it take to infect
a host and that varies for every virus
and for every host it may vary for one
virus and all of us in this room it may
take different numbers of virus the same
virus to infect all of us would you like
to try an experiment no we can't do that
many variables conspired to kill
complicate the issue host genetics we
are all out bred of course host
antiviral defenses viral virulence the
particular gene composition of the virus
make a difference the social behavior of
the hosts the age and even the weather
and the environment can make a
difference for example the natural
environment is a considerable barrier to
infection these are very small viruses
for the most part remember you can't see
them they're tiny being blown around by
air currents so at once their release
from the host they face huge obstacles
there's a big dilution effect so
effective multiplicities when you are
infected are quite low very different
from a cell culture dish sunlight is bad
for viruses the UV light will inactivate
the genome it will also dry it out and a
lot of viruses can't take that the
chemical environment can also reduce the
numbers of infectious viruses many
viruses are sensitive to heat drying and
sunlight and many viruses overcome this
obstacle by making a lot of progeny and
they figure if I make billions of
viruses a few will get through and
infect the host so this is one of the
selective forces for making large
numbers of progeny humans of course
don't have the same approach we make
very few because we try to ensure that
we all survive many many viruses are
also stable to low pH or proteases and
those are the ones that can that can
last in the environment on cooking
surfaces in a cruise ship for example
and so that you can transmit it on to
other people these are particularly
viruses that are passed in the
alimentary tract that are transmitted by
fecal oral transmission and their
waterborne infections some viruses never
experience the environment the life
cycles involve insect vectors the
mosquito or some other vector bites you
and delivers the virus right into your
cells so that virus doesn't have to deal
with the environment at all it
multiplies in you and that it's picked
up by another insect vector and
transmitted to another person and some
infections are spread by physical
contact of course transferred by body
fluids
and in that case the viruses are not
outside for long so there are many these
are all different ways that viruses can
be
mitad and the viruses have evolved to be
effective by their ways so a virus
transferred by an insect vector would
not be stable to sunlight ultraviolet
light and drying but many respiratory
viruses have evolved to be relatively
stable under those conditions the
getting into the host is a crucial part
of initiating infection and as humans we
have a limited spectrum of sites for
viral infection we are mostly covered
with skin and of course the outer layer
is dead so viruses cannot replicate in
the skin if you just put viruses on your
skin they will sit there unless you have
a cut or some kind of abrasion a virus
will not be able to replicate so we're
pretty well protected the problem is we
have these mucosal surfaces and we have
this respiratory and alimentary tract we
have eyes yura genital tracts these have
nicely exposed epithelial surfaces which
are not protected as well as the skin
and that's where most of the virus
infections initiate and of course we
need to have mucosal surfaces because we
have to exchange material with the
environment we have to respire annex
fire and eat food and expel it and so
forth so it's a property of our
evolution that we have these susceptible
surfaces and that's where viruses come
in so here is here is a diagram of some
of the places that viruses come in the
eyes they have we have nice mucous
membranes there the respiratory
elementary and urogenital tracts also
and even though the skin is protected
vector bites can get viruses beneath the
dead outer layer a scan scratches
needlesticks dog bites etc so there are
ways to get past the skin the skin is a
good barrier as I've said unless broken
up it's impervious to infection but we
do that regularly as you know and so we
do get a lot of infections in the skid
we have the surface being dead shells
and those that land on the skin can be
inactivated by drying the skin is rather
acidic and there are other mic we now
are learning that there is a whole
microbiome back to
and other organisms living on our skin
and many of those secrete compounds that
protect us interestingly we don't
totally understand this yet but there
are many bacteria on all of us that
probably are barriers to infection with
pathogens normal skin is a low pH so the
outer layer the epidermis the top layer
is dead and you cannot infect it as we
said unless you puncture it
but many ways to do that skin abrasions
insect their animal bites needle
punctures once you get below the
epidermis then you have lots of blood
vessels and lymph vessels and the
viruses that can get in there then can
spread to other sites so if you if you
infect the very upper layers there is
not a lot of vascular ization than
transport they're not easy for viruses
to spread but if they can get to the
underlying layers the dermis then they
can spread to other tissues mucosal
surfaces are terrific places to initiate
a viral infection it's a wet moist
environment so there's no drying out not
much UV light for the most part and
there are there are some other primary
defenses that protect them but they are
nice vulnerable sites let's take a look
at the respiratory tract this turns out
to be the most common route of virus
entry why huge absorptive area 140
square meters in your lung so it's
amazing six liters per minute of a
ventilation rate a lot of alveoli so
you're always sampling the air six
liters emitted is a lot and so as I said
the air is full of viruses so the tract
the respiratory tract is a good place to
introduce them there are lots of
replicating cells and you have easy
access to the blood from the respiratory
tract and typically we get viral
infections by aerosolized droplets
someone is coughing or sneezing or just
talking you know and talking you expel a
lot of droplets and if I had a virus
infection if I had a measles virus
infection you would all be getting
measles of course the year all immunized
so you wouldn't be doing that nowadays
but in the old days before immunization
diesels person standing in front of the
room with measles would infect everyone
from these little droplets going out and
carrying viruses and healthy people the
respiratory tract defenses are strong we
have mucus 20 to 200 milliliters of the
day if mucus of course you don't see
most of it because it remains in your
tract it's good that you don't see most
of it I don't want to see most of your
200 ml of mucus either but you have a
lot of mucus and that's an important
defense because it traps pathogens
viruses as well as bacteria spores and
if you inhale these particles and they
get down into your lower track the mucus
is brought back up by ciliary action and
then you swallow it isn't it wonderful
you swallow the mucus and you inactivate
all these respiratory viruses and that
you do that whether you like it or not
you are always swallowing this the
mucosal iary escalator we call it it
moves the mucus from lungs to esophagus
at 1 centimeter a minute so now you know
what is going on as you're sitting there
listening to me
you also filter particles out in your
sinuses to a certain extent so in
addition to these physical methods we
also have immune cells in our lower
track with macrophages and other kinds
of cells we have antibodies if you have
been previously infected so we do have
some good protection and that is why we
stay healthy so here is a typical
respiratory tract going from the upper
to the lower track it is lined with a
epithelial cell layer shown here nice
brush border epithelial cells
interspersed with goblet cells that
produce mucus and these epithelial cells
are ciliated and that pushes the mucus
up towards your esophagus so that you
can swallow it viruses can replicate
throughout the track that can replicate
from the upper to the lower tract and
when they do so and you have symptoms
they have different names like rhinitis
the common cold the very upper tract
infections pharyngitis or laryngitis and
all the way down to tracheitis
bronchitis bronchiolitis and
bronchopneumonia and some viruses can
rep
at both sites and cause various
syndromes and others are restricted on
this slide which is somewhat outdated
now we see rhinovirus is a upper tract
pathogen this is what we thought for
many years but now there is new evidence
that in fact rhinoviruses can also cause
pneumonia
which of course is an infection of the
lower tract as well the alimentary tract
is also a wonderful place to meet new
viruses eating drinking and other social
activities routinely introduced viruses
there the alimentary tract is designed
to digest food right it's always in
motion especially after you eat good
opportunity for a virus to interact with
a cell and that's what of course the
virus has to do it has to attach to a
cell lining the gut tract so this
movement provides that opportunity the
gut though is more hostile than the
respiratory tract the stomach is acidic
the intestine is alkaline we have
enzymes bile detergents mucus antibodies
phagocytic cells everywhere so this is
part of the reason why we stay healthy
nevertheless viruses can go through all
of this poliovirus you can ingest it
will pass all the way through your
stomach and small intestine and
replicate in your small intestine there
are even viruses that require protease
is in your gut to activate them for
infection those are some of the real
viruses so Nora will talk a little bit
about some of those wonderful
gastroenteritis viruses later those are
the real viruses and the norovirus that
can pass through your gut that's also
lined with a epithelial layer you have
villi of course and the villi are
composed of layers or sheets of
epithelial cells magnified up here and
those are called enterocytes some
viruses can multiply in the intro sites
there are also specialized cells
interspersed among the anthro sites
they're called M cells these are
involved in sampling the antigenic
content of the lumen of the gut and
saying whether there are bad things
moving around
that we should be taking notice of this
is so you can view the intestinal tract
very much like the lung as a selectively
permeable barrier it needs to take in
food that you have eaten of course
so viruses take advantage of that and
because we have these M cells these M
cells sampling the antigen content of
the lumen there are immune cells right
below them you see lymphocytes and
macrophages very close to the M cell
here is in fact a electron micrograph of
an M cell is a section of gut here's the
M cell and here are the entr sites on
either side lymphocytes and macrophages
underneath so the function of those
cells is who patrol the the M cell the M
cell is bringing in material from the
gut they're very active at trans cytosis
they take in material here they put it
below to these antigen sampling cells
and they look at it and say whether it's
a problem or not but - but viruses
exploit that here is in fact infection
of an N cell by real viruses these
little particles here real viruses have
exploited this uptake mechanism this
transite OSIS by which viruses go from
the lumen into the underlying tissues
your genital tract is also a site of
infection that is protected by mucus and
low pH but abrasions from sexual
activity may allow viruses to get across
the membrane there so these membranes
are not as well developed at taking up
material like the respiratory and the
elementary tract is but abrasions allow
viruses to enter viruses like human
papilloma virus may produce local
lesions when they infect there others
can infect the urogenital tract and then
spread to other sites like HIV and
herpes simplex virus the eye is also a
route of entry this sclera and the
conjunctiva typically infected by
viruses you blink every few seconds and
as you do you wash away foreign
particles and that's a wonderful defense
because any virus that lands on your eye
is immediately washed away
and therefore has a little opportunity
to infect but if you get some grit in
your eye and you rub it then you get
little micro abrasions on your eye
surface then that will let virus
particles in so typically infection
occurs after some kind of injury grit
ophthalmological procedures not using
sterilized instruments or hot tubs or
swimming pools that aren't properly
sanitized many examples of adenovirus
eye infections from people going in a
hot tub where there wasn't enough
chlorine and then over the next few days
everybody gets red eyes like this one
it's a subconjunctival bleed caused by a
viral infection so a localized infection
of the eye is called conjunctivitis and
some viruses produced this wonderful red
eye which is very scary but it's for the
most part harmless goes away some
viruses can infect the eye and spread
enterovirus 70 which can cause
conjunctivitis can in some cases spread
back we think via the optic nerve into
the brain and cause paralysis herpes
simplex virus can infect the cornea and
can cause blindness the virus can also
spread to sensory ganglia so virus
infections of the eye are not trivial so
here's a summary of all the different
routes of virus entry and those you
should be familiar with just the general
ways that virus can get in all these
pathways that I've talked about how a
virus might enter the respiratory tract
the alimentary tract for example and as
we talked about these viruses you'll
remember that poliovirus and rotavirus
is in fact via the alimentary tract
you'll remember that HIV can infect by
the urogenital tract as well okay so you
are infected by any of these routes the
skin respiratory alimentary your genital
etcetera and we've talked about just how
they are open to virus infection let's
now talk about how viruses spread from
those initial sites all right now some
viruses don't spread some of them
replicate where
they come in so here we have a gut
epithelium and a virus can infect these
enterocytes and just spread throughout
the NRO sites and never go underneath
and spread to the rest of the organism
so the virus spreads within the
epithelium but it is contained by the
tissue structure and the immune system
so what I mean by that the tissue
structure below these epithelial layers
is what is called a basement membrane
this is not really a membrane but a
structure made up of a variety of
proteins and proteoglycans but it is a
barrier to routine penetration of the
sub epithelial tissues by microorganisms
so down here below the epithelium is the
sub epithelial tissue and there are
blood vessels and lymph lymph vessels
there and so if you got there you could
pretty much go anywhere in the organism
so the structure of this is such to
prevent that so some viruses in fact are
blocked by that there are also some
immune responses at the surface that
will prevent further infection but other
viruses can spread beyond this primary
site again it could be a respiratory
epithelium Elementary tract it doesn't
really matter when that happens we say
that these are disseminated infections
and when many organs are infected we
call it a systemic infection so it's
again that's spreading from the primary
site to other places to ways of
describing that in order to do that the
virus must breach this physical barrier
as well as immune barriers to get below
the into the sub Pepa thelia tissues so
there is the basement membrane and its
integrity as you can see in this picture
can be compromised by inflammation and
destruction so inflammation of couse of
course is the recruitment of immune
cells and the production of cytokines to
in an area and these can disrupt the
basement membrane so the intent is good
the immune cells want to get rid of
infection but in doing so they're
causing damage and that allows viruses
to pass into the sub epithelial tissues
some viruses of course can destroy both
the cell and the basement membrane just
by replicating in them
that allows easy passage but again not
every virus that infects these sites can
do these things it's quite selective so
the sub epithelial tissues are the key
to a disseminated infection the virus
encounters fluids lymphatic system and
phagocytes and the phagocytes of course
are there to try and clear the infection
but they could pick up a virus and bring
it somewhere else
inadvertently spreading the infection so
that's how you come to get into other
tissues from one of these epithelial
barriers by penetrating the basement
membrane and then spreading beyond it
now these are all polarized cells of
course they have an apical a basal
lateral domain and there are also
lateral domains between the cells and
viruses it turns out are produced
sometimes at one of the two surfaces
that apical or basal lateral or both and
I want to show you an experiment that
illustrates how important it is where a
virus is produced to the to the
pathogenesis of that infection so this
is a couple of electron micrographs
illustrating apical and basal lateral
production remember viruses can be
produced by budding from the cell
membrane in a culture dish these cells
are not polarized I just have one
membrane and the virus's old bud from
the top but in our bodies cells are
polarized and here's influenza virus
budding from the apical domain of a
polarized epithelial cell
here's measles virus budding from the
apical domain so if this were your
respiratory tract this is great right
because the virus is budding into the
lumen and you cough and you spread it if
the virus was budding just in the
basolateral side coughing wouldn't
spread the infection to others so these
viruses have evolved to be transmitted
by the respiratory route by virtue in
part of their being produced at the
apical domain now vesicular stomatitis
virus is produced at the basolateral
domain of polarized epithelial cells is
not typically a virus that is spread in
a respiratory route these are in animals
can be spread by vectors it's typically
an animal infection
and among animals usually spread by
vectors so it doesn't need to be spread
in an apical way now so basolateral
release provides access to underlying
tissues remember the basement membrane
is here below this epithelial sheet and
if the virus is but down they have
potentially the ability to get past the
basement membrane if they bud just from
the top of the cell they're not going to
get below it there's no way that's gonna
happen but that is good for other
purposes of course so here's a nice
example of how you can manipulate this
and change the pathogenesis sendai virus
is a negative stranded envelope virus
you can infect mice with sendai virus
and the virus is released from the
apical domain of the respiratory tract
and if you infect mice with a wild type
virus it's causes a respire Tori tract
infection and it never spreads to any
other tissues but you can make a mutant
of the virus by introducing a couple of
amino acid changes in the virus and that
mutant is now released from both the
apical and the basolateral domains of
the cell so what do you think happens
when you infect mice with that mutant
well the virus spreads systemically it
then infects multiple organs and is
lethal to the mouse so the simple
attribute of being able to bud from the
basolateral domain of a cell enables a
virus to spread whereas otherwise if it
were just coming off the tops of the
cells wouldn't be able to do that now
how do the virus is actually spread one
way is via the blood we call this
hematogenous spread and when a virus
makes a disseminated infection the
systemic infection infecting multiple
organs it may do so by entering the
blood obviously the blood can carry it
everywhere so it has opportunity to
infect many different organs the viruses
can enter the blood directly through
capillaries or so if a blood if a virus
gets beyond the basement membrane it's
now in the subject a filial tissues it
can directly enter capillaries could be
introduced then into them by vector
bites of
and then can get in the blood and spread
everywhere but also virus in these sub
epithelial tissues can be taken up by
lymphatic capillaries and that brings
them to lymph nodes and eventually of
course the lymph system joins with the
blood and so the virus will eventually
reach the blood by this route lymph
capillaries tend to be more permeable
than circulatory circulatory capillaries
so it's a very good way for viruses to
get into the circulation from the sub
epithelial tissues so that's
hematogenous spread when you have virus
in the blood it is called very Mia and
this is a graph showing a couple of
different kinds of viremia here we have
infected an animal with a virus and at
different times after infection we are
measuring the virus in the blood so you
could just take the blood and do a
plaque assay for if the virus forms
black or do something else so here after
you inoculate the animal you see there's
a lot of virus in the blood right away
that's what you put in that's what
that's the virus you inject it into the
animal we call that a passive viremia
because you get it by injecting virus
into the animal those titers then go
down and after a couple of days you get
another rise in virus titer and this is
from virus replication somewhere in the
animal we don't know where in this
particular experiment we call it a
primary very Mia because it is the
result of multiplication of the inoculum
somewhere and this is a very typical
pattern of virus infections that are
spread by the blood you then have a
secondary viremia so the virus is
produced initially by this primary
multiplication they spread to other
tissues and then they molt they seed
those tissues and multiply again in
those and then you have a larger burst
of secondary viremia
very typical pattern measles virus for
example does this and many other viruses
as well so primary is the virus released
into the blood after the initial
replication at the site of entry the
secondary is produced by disseminated
infections we diagnose virus infections
many virus infections by the presence of
virus in the blood
we don't usually measure virus anymore
we either do antigen tests or PCR type
assays but we're looking for virus in
the blood and of course this has a
practical consequence that if our blood
supply of course is donated blood we
haven't figured out yet how to make
synthetic blood so we have to get people
to donate blood and they could have a
virus infection of some sort so we do
screen for a number of viruses in the
blood supply including HIV of course and
htlv and the old of hepatitis virus is a
b c d e and probably G but I'm not sure
okay so we have to get rid of these
viruses otherwise people would get sick
but we don't screen the blood for all
viruses there are viruses in the blood
that we don't pay attention to because
we're not sure they're a problem and
rather than get everyone annoyed or
upset we just we just let them stay
there now here's the pathogenesis of a
mouse infection which was done by Frank
Fenner who just died a couple of months
ago and he was the first to show how
these disseminated viral infections
developed and he used a mouse model of
smallpox called Mouse pox and he showed
you inoculate a virus locally and it
does a primary and a secondary viremia
and you get seeding of target organs so
here you inoculate the mouse in the foot
pad initially here's the virus going and
the foot pad initially multiplies in the
epithelial cells just below where you
have inoculated it gets below the
basement membrane look and it's
spreading through the regional lymph
nodes into the blood so all those things
we talked about Fred Frank Fenner was
essential for us understanding all of
those steps so the mouse box is gone by
day 2 into the blood and that brings it
to the spleen and to the liver and the
virus multiplies there of course the
blood stream virus that I'm showing here
is the primary very Mia because it's
multiplied in the skin initially then it
multiplies in the spleen and liver and
you get a secondary viremia as virus
comes out of those organs and then the
virus goes
to the skin so from a footpad
inoculation it is gone very meek to the
spleen and liver causing problems there
it's killing it's causing necrosis of
those organs and then it gets to the
skin and that gives you these rash we
early rashes and late severe rashes
which are typical of Mouse pox so that
that virus spread from the foot pad to
the skin via these roots so a typical
course of infection measles is very
similar you inhale measles its
respiratory transmitted gets into your
bloodstream from the respiratory tract
and spreads by a via primary and
secondary viremia and eventually you get
a rash all from inhaling this virus so
these are some viruses that cause rashes
in people of course smallpox was the big
rash virus infection but we don't have
smallpox anymore we have eradicated it
the only virus infection that we've ever
eradicated but we still have Coxsackie
measles parvo viruses rubella varicella
zoster that caused various types of
rashes so virus is spreading in the
blood now we can also spread via neural
roots
it's called neural spread many viruses
spread from the primary site by entering
local nerve endings you nerve endings
everywhere of course and why not why
can't a virus get in it and for some
viruses this spread is an essential part
of the pathogenesis like rabies alpha
herpes viruses that is how they spread
in you by going through your nerve
fibers for other viruses it seems to be
an accident
polio virus real virus invasion of the
CNS is a rare diversion from the normal
spread of these viruses which is
typically through the blood but in a
very few cases and a low percentage of
infections these viruses will enter the
CNS and cause problems and we'll talk
about that in more detail as we
highlight specific infections later so
here is a diagram of how viruses can
spread within the CNS so here for
example is a sensory nerve ending
alright so your skin of course
highly innervated that's why you feel
pain under certain conditions the nerve
fibers go back to the CNS many viruses
can enter sensory nerve endings they're
transported up the nerve fibers by
motors all the way up to neurons oh this
is a motor this is a muscle of course
which is innervated eventually by a
motor neuron and viruses can also enter
the neuromuscular Junction and be
transported up the nerve fibers as well
polio virus for example goes from the
neuromuscular Junction all the way into
the spinal cord to the motor neuron that
innervates this muscle and these of
course are connected by additional
fibers to the primary neurons in the
brain and the viruses can follow these
pathways they can also come out of the
CNS into peripheral sites as well so the
travel can be in both directions here's
a nice picture of the movement of virus
and nerves this is a herpes virus that
has been engineered to express green
fluorescent protein and what was done
here was to inject the virus in a very
specific place in the CNS and then the
virus has spread from neuron to neuron
via the axons and dendrites and you can
actually map neuronal circuitry using
viruses in this way you can inject them
at very specific places and watch where
they connect to and map out the tracings
in this way it's very interesting
application of this reagent as I said
poliovirus uses a neural spread polio is
a virus you acquire by ingesting the
virus and it goes into your mucosal
surfaces in your elementary tract that
replicates in the mucosa gets past the
basement membrane and reaches your blood
and in most infections that's the end of
the infection you get a little fever
perhaps but you you the infection stops
after about a week you shed virus in the
feces because it's multiplying in this
epithelial cells and you spread it to
other people but for the most part
you're okay and about one percent of
infected individuals the virus enters
the CNS
probably does so from the motor endplate
the virus gets into your muscle from the
circulation spreads up the nerve fiber
all the way to the spinal cord and then
the virus multiplies in the neurons the
motor neurons in the spinal cord spreads
there and as it destroys them it causes
paralysis so that's an example of
neuronal spread now as while we're
talking about infections of the central
nervous system let's let's put up some
terminology neurotropic virus is a virus
that can infect nerve cells it's all it
means doesn't imply anything about how
the virus gets to the nerve cell it just
means that the virus can infect such
cells a neuro invasive virus is one that
can enter the CNS after you put it at a
peripheral site so if I put a virus into
my finger and it gets into my CNS it is
neuro invasive if it replicates in the
CNS it's neurotropic your invasiveness
doesn't mean it's nootropic new or
invasive just means it can get into the
CNS a neuro virulent virus can cause
disease in the CNS and that's all it
means it doesn't mean that it's neuro
invasive and it doesn't mean that it is
neurotropic although it should be so for
example herpes simplex virus has low
neuro invasiveness so it's not easy to
get in from peripheral sites but once
it's there it's a very newer virulent
mumps virus is highly neuro invasive but
of loner and neurovirulence at one time
before immunization we are all now
immunized against mumps the measles
mumps rubella vaccine MMR prevents those
three infections but before that kids
all got mumps in their in their young
years and you get the characteristic
swelling of your salivary glands and
half and those kids all recover they
were fine the half of those kids the
virus was in their brain but it didn't
cause any problems because it's
very--it's of low newer virulence so the
virus could get in your brain it's neuro
invasive replicate a little bit
neurotropic but not not neuro virulent
at all quite interesting and finally we
have rabies which is the worst calm
in highly neuro invasive and highly
neurovirulence so if you are bitten
peripherally with a by a rabid dog the
virus gets into your CNS pretty much
100% of the time and you're dead there
is no there are very few people who have
survived rabies infection without being
immunized there are a couple though okay
so we are spreading by the blood we are
spreading by nerves now we have to get
into tissues to cause infection of
tissues for example mouse pox in fact
the deliver and the spleen polio
infecting other tissues how does the
virus get from the blood or from the
nerves into a tissue in order to
multiply so here we're talking about
tissue innovation and this is large in
largely determined by the structure of
the blood vessels that are carrying the
virus so here we have three different
configurations of these structures here
we have an example where we have the
blood vessel shown here
you know capillaries are formed by
endothelial cells and if they're very
tightly joined things can't get through
them very easily so here's the nucleus
of this endothelial cell so it's very
tightly joined plus there's a basement
membrane around it so here the virus has
a lot of trouble getting across and this
is typical in the CNS connective tissue
skeletal and cardiac muscle very
difficult for viruses to cross the
capillaries in those tissue we have
another configuration here where there
are pores between the endothelial cells
so that lets virus through there is
still a basement membrane but this is a
little more permeable you find this in
the kidney pancreas ileum and the colon
and then in some tissues the blood
vessel is not really a blood vessel it's
just a couple of cells sitting on the
walls of the tissue making what we call
a sinusoidal and this is there's no
basement membrane the endothelial cells
are not even joined so it's very easy
for viruses to get through so that's
typical of liver that's why it's very
easy for viruses to get into your liver
so this is a very important determinant
of how viruses can get into various
tissues in order to multiply here
just an illustration of the liver here's
a sinusoid it's really just a passage
through the liver so the the cells
hepatocyte s-- form this passage and
then there may be cells like here we're
showing cup for cells lining this
passage so viruses that pass through
here readily taken up either into the
cup for cells or directly into the PATA
sites where they can multiply and spread
now not every virus multiplies in the
liver fortunately only a few can do that
it's very easy to get into this organ
the brain is a tough site to get into
because it has those very tight
endothelial cells and has the basement
membrane but it is not impossible
so there is a functionally described
so-called blood-brain barrier and this
is what makes it difficult for certain
drugs to get from the blood into the
brain because of these tight junctions
also makes it difficult for viruses to
get through but some viruses can do it
not a lot of viruses can get into the
brain or the CNS but there are a few
that do and those those routes of entry
are illustrated here you can have so
here is a capillary lumen so the virus
is trying to get from the lumen into the
brain matter proper surrounding it some
virus is actually replicated in the
endothelial cells but that they both
they bind to receptors multiply and get
through that way some can be taken up by
trans cytosis without multiplying so
they're taking up into the and acidic
system from one side and put on the
other and sometimes if these viruses are
present in lymphocytes or monocytes
these cells are very good at squeezing
through the capillary endothelial cells
and so they bring the viruses with them
so those cells have adapted to squeeze
through here and so they are like Trojan
horses so that was just a single blood
vessel in the CNS here's the whole
picture which summarizes all the ways
that viruses can get into the CNS so we
have nerve neural spread right which can
come from peripheral nerves
from the spinal cord from peripheral
muscles so there are a variety of neural
roots of spread of virus into the CNS
and of course once the virus comes in
that way it's already in the tissue so
it's real it's there into the paren coma
and here are some examples of various
entry routes from blood vessels so there
are many ngo blood vessels of course
so viruses can cross those blood vessels
by the mechanisms we just talked about
and once they're there they're in the
CSF they can spread to many other places
viruses can also enter the CSF and the
choroid plexus so that is an organ here
that is responsible for producing the
cerebrospinal fluid the choroid plexus
is lined with what are called ependymal
cells envira some viruses replicate in
these ependymal cells and pass through
into the CSF and again once you're there
you can spread everywhere and finally
there are cerebral blood vessels through
which virus can pass and enter the brain
parenchyma and so for example the virus
could then replicate in a neuron or an
astrocyte or glial cell so this is a
rare event virus entering the CNS but it
can be done and then once the viruses
are in there it's big problems because
the CNS isn't particularly good at
having a strong immune response to
prevent infection it's almost as if it
hasn't evolved to prevent infection very
well because it assumes that has put up
a physical barrier that would prevent it
now an important concept in pathogenesis
is tissue tropism and this simply means
the the spectrum of tissues that are
infected by a given virus so we talked
about enteric viruses enter atrophic
viruses we talked about neurotropic
viruses replicating in the nervous
system and not elsewhere have Patou
tropic viruses for example these viruses
have a particular pattern of replication
and that's what we call tropism so not
every virus replicates in every tissue
there's always a subset and we call that
the tropism of the virus so some viruses
have a limited tropism
and others are what we call pan tropic
they've IRA they replicate in many
organs and we would like to know what
controls this what makes a virus
replicate in just one tissue and what
allows it to replicate in many because
if we can understand that maybe we can
control the replication in various ways
by intervening so what are the
determinants of tissue tropism well one
is susceptibility right the presence of
receptors if a tissue doesn't have a
receptor it's not going to be infected
so that's a pretty simple one then
there's permittivity that is what
happens in the cell beyond the entry
step well the proteins that the virus
needs to replicate intracellular gene
products if they're not present the cell
is not going to be permissive
accessibility is also important the
virus has to be able to reach the cells
that are both permissive and susceptible
it made contact cells that are not and
that doesn't do it any good and the host
defenses so these all combined to
determine tropism so physical and innate
defenses at the site of infection will
determine whether the virus is able to
replicate there or not so even if you
have cells with receptors that are
permissive and can be accessed by the
virus it may not replicate because the
defense really is very efficient at
preventing infection now going back to
the first determinant of tropism the
receptor there are some cases where the
receptor is regulating tropism of
viruses but for the most part they don't
seem to be so for example influenza
virus the receptor is sialic acid which
is on every tissue yet this virus is
largely limited in humans to the
respiratory tract poliovirus is limited
to the alimentary tract and to motor
neurons but the poliovirus receptor is
in most organs so often receptors do not
track with the tropism of a virus
infection but other things
can control tropism and here's one
example for influenza virus now if you
remember the structure of influenza
viruses the viral membrane is studded
with glycoproteins and one of those the
H a is essential for attaching to host
cell receptors and then it has to
catalyze fusion with the endosome as the
virus enters the cell remember all that
know okay if you call the H a has to be
cleaved in order to undergo acid
catalyzed fusion if it's not cleave that
won't do that because the n-terminal
fusion peptide will not be exposed
cleavage is an essential determinant of
flu tropism so here is a respiratory
epithelium which is producing influenza
virus and there is a cell in the
epithelium called a Klara cell that
produces a protease which Cleaves the
hemagglutinin of influenza virus this
protease is only made in the respiratory
tract so this virus that's produced is
cleave than it can infect other cells in
the respiratory tract now let's say some
of these influenza viruses somehow get
to your liver
there's no protease klara in your liver
so those viruses will infect the liver
cell but then the virus is produced by
the liver cell won't have cleave DHA so
they can't infect any other liver cells
so that's why influenza is not a Patou
tropic because there's no protease this
is why the virus is restricted to the
respiratory tract because there the
protease is produced so that's one
example of how a protease can determine
tropism now this is an even broader
application for influenza virus this
cleavage of the H a some highly virulent
avian strains of influenza have a
sequence of multiple basic amino acids
at the H a cleavage site so in human
strains the H a cleavage site is only
cleaved by this respiratory protease
klara but there are virus flu viruses
that infect birds that wipe out in
flocks of birds and these guys have
multiple basic amino acids at the
cleavage site and what that does it lets
the virus be cleaved by ubiquitous
protease is that is protease is that our
in every cell in the bird so the flu
viruses and birds can replicate
everywhere because every cell has the
protease to activate the H a that's why
these in part are particularly virulent
so the viruses can infect multiple
organs of the bird back in 1997 avian
influenza viruses of this type we'll
talk about what this means a bit later
these were isolated from 16 people in
Hong Kong first time that so many people
had been infected with a h5n1 avian
influenza virus so it was a little scary
and these viruses were isolated in
sequenced and they they were found to
have this basic amino acid insertion at
the H a cleavage site these were very
sick people and the evidence was that
the virus had multiplied in multiple
organs so we think that was because this
cleavage site now could be activated in
multiple organs as well interestingly
the 1918 strain which killed millions
and millions of people does not have
these changes so this is not a pan
tropic strain this is just a highly
virulent strain
we'll come back to this later when we
talk more about influenza virus now
shedding of the virus is important
because you can only transmit an
infection and maintain it in a
population if you effectively shed the
virus and it can affect other people so
the virus has to be released from you
from the infected individual and that is
typically required for spread of the
virus in a population the exceptions of
course or viruses that spread in the
germ line so endogenous retroviruses
don't have an extracellular phase or
they don't have to because they're
passed from mother to offspring
parent to offspring via the germline so
there's no transmission virus is spread
in the blood supply same thing they're
just injected into you so there's no
extra so there's no extra host phase if
but all other viruses have to spread and
this shedding can be at the primary site
of replication where the virus say first
goes into your lungs or it can be at
distal sites if you have lesions on your
skin which result after spread of the
virus from a respiratory infection that
can spread the infection as well and the
number of particles of course is crucial
for transmission you have to make a lot
to transmit effectively respiratory
secretions our aerosols produced by
coughing and sneezing and speaking as I
have said sneezing makes 20,000 droplets
so if you're making influenza virus each
of those droplets is full of influenza
virus and the big drop so people have
studied these droplets very seriously
they measure their sizes of you when you
sneeze the big drops fall right near you
the big wet ones and then the small ones
go far so you could I could sneeze here
and Saul would be infected in the back
of the room with my small droplets very
very small droplets so these are quote
the small ones are called droplet nuclei
I want the 4 microns they remain
suspended and you inhale them they can
go all the way down into your alveoli
and infect the lower tract and of course
also you can spread with respiratory
infections by nasal secretions you touch
your nose and you get some virus on your
fingers and you shake hands with someone
or you can even put it on the doorknob
and you know this is this room hundreds
of people come in and out of it
everything that I would love to sample
that doorknob and see what happens last
year I said I wanted a sample a subway
poll for viruses and the next week one
of the students brought me a swab that
he it's the same it's still in my
freezer so here is some sneezing
pictures which I always like to show
here the big juicy droplets here which
are going to fall to the ground and the
little ones that the edge of the sneeze
are going to spread quite away so these
are illuminated from behind so you can
see this but when all of you sneeze you
do this coughing make smaller plumes but
it also makes a plume and even speaking
and certain words are very good at
making plumes like pees so all of these
things can cause virus shedding
feces is a major means of spread of
viruses in underdeveloped countries but
it still occurs in wealthy nations as
well we routinely contaminate our water
with sewage we have food handlers who
are shedding viruses and don't wash
their hands and contaminate food and so
forth the blood of course is also
transmitting viruses we have vector
bites healthcare workers get infected
even though we're careful about the
blood supply there's a lot of
blood-borne transmission urine also
hantavirus --is are spread from mice to
human by mouse urine HIV herpes viruses
hepatitis B virus and semen a mouse
virus can even be transmitted to the
offspring via milk skin lesions will
also transmit viruses papilloma virus
warts pox viruses and even a type of
herpes popular among college wrestlers
called herpes gladiatori you know these
guys are in there rubbing each other and
they transmit this wonderful infection
of a herpes virus very efficiently so as
I said the spread of infection is needed
to maintain the chain of infection we
have typically two general patterns of
transmission we have perpetuation in one
species or the alternate infection of
insect and vertebrate hosts so if this
infection in one species influenza going
back and forth among humans or a vector
borne disease a mosquito carrying a
virus either among humans or between an
animal and a human
most of the human viruses it turns out
are transmitted from human to human most
of the ones we know about so the humans
are the reservoir for the virus okay so
we are the reservoir for most of our
infections even influenza we know a lot
of strains in originated in birds and in
swine but we are the reservoir when
there are outbreaks we spread it from
person to person and as I said there are
some vector human and vector vertebrate
cycles that maintain transmission
the virus when we talk about a virus
going from an animal to a human we call
it a zoonosis a viral disease shared by
humans and animals so hantavirus
pulmonary syndrome which originated in
the four corners of the u.s. came
originally from a virus and mouse in
mice transmitted to humans and that's a
zoonosis because it jumped from the
mouse to humans so here are some
examples of transmission routes of
different popular viruses we have the
respiratory route of course coughing
sneezing and so forth fecal oral
transmission contact zoonosis
transmitted by vectors of various type
or animal bites rabies the blood many
infections transmitted by the blood
sexual contact from mother to child
including the very important
cytomegalovirus and herpes simplex virus
and the retrovirus is transmitted
through the germ I use the endogenous
retroviruses so these are all the ways
of transmission that we know about
typically the where you produce viruses
of course and their stability is going
to determine the route of transmission
so an interrogate replicates in the gut
obviously is going to be spread by fecal
oral contamination envelope viruses tend
to be fragile
so they are largely transmitted either
by aerosols or by injection or organ
transplantation non-enveloped viruses
are a lot more Hardy they can withstand
the alimentary tract high temperatures
and these are often transmitted by also
respiratory routes fecal-oral routes
where the envelope viruses in general
fail or fomites contaminated material so
the contaminated doorknob would be a Pho
mite and we also have some interesting
terms when we talk about transmission of
virus infections actually all infections
ATRA genic where the activity of a
healthcare worker leads to infection of
the patient and included in that is no
so
kamil infection where and individuals
infected when you are in a hospital or a
health care facility vertical
transmission is from parent to offspring
so the transmission of viruses from
mother to offspring via the germline is
included in that and other for all other
forms are horizontal transmission so if
you are bitten by a mosquito or you are
you pick up a virus from a doorknob this
is horizontal transmission vertical is
from parent to offspring
and finally as part of the germ line
such as pro viral DNA interestingly
geography and season off also have a
large role in regulating patterns of
infection and this is so often because
the vector or the animal reservoir is
geographically restricted in some way
and global travel has really made a big
impact on this before we had extensive
global travel the spread of viruses was
or the distribution I should say was far
more restricted than it is today with
airplane travel being incredibly
accessible the spread of viruses has has
increased enormously we'll talk about
that in emerging virus infections and an
example of the effect of geography and
vector and its effect on the vector is
chikungunya virus how a vector can
affect the localization of viral
infection so chikungunya is a member of
the toga virus family it is spread by a
mosquito Aedes aegypti and when you are
infected with with this virus
you get typically a rash and joint pains
it's prevalent it was originally
prevalent for many years in Asia and
Africa never found in Europe or the
United States until 2004 a series of
outbreaks spread from Kenya to India and
then a few years later yeah there was an
outbreak in Italy the first in Europe
the vector one that one of the vectors
for chikungunya is now another mosquito
the Asian tiger mosquito Aedes
albopictus so this is the distribution
of of this mosquito in the u.s. in the
year 2000 so it's continuing to spread
westward we as it we still don't have
chikungunya virus in the US but the
virus has adopted to be able to grow in
this mosquito in other places so
previously this virus only was vectored
by 80s at gypped I as it spread from
Africa to India in Europe the the virus
underwent a single mutation in the one
of the glycoproteins which allowed it to
now be vectored by ATS albopictus so in
Europe it is often vectored by that
mosquito so eventually it might reach
the u.s. an example of how the initial
distribution of the virus was restricted
by the vector Aedes aegypti and now with
its expansion into a new vector the
range of the virus is increasing season
will also infect virus infections so
what time of year it is in certain
climates here is rubella from 1963 to
1968 a seasonal peak in the spring here
is influenza which of course appear in
our climate and our temperate climates
is a winter infection even polio virus
exhibited some seasonality and this
actually varied according to latitude so
you can see it at these latitudes 35 to
70 degrees predominantly in September 25
to 55 degrees latitude predominantly in
March why is this well we for the most
part don't know how virus infections are
regulated by the season but there are
some interesting data for influenza
virus which I'd like to tell you about
and these data were acquired using a
guinea-pig model of transmission which
was actually developed here in New York
at Mount Sinai and what you do is you
put guinea pigs in
racks so you have one rack here you have
another rack next to it and you have a
fan blowing air across the racks right
and you infect the guinea pigs in this
rack and then you look at the
transmission to the second rack and then
the transmits very effectively and what
they did in these experiments was to
regulate the temperature and the
humidity which of course may be part of
the seasonality of infections the
differences in temperature and humidity
and what they found was that low
relative humidities were the most
efficient for the most favorable for
transmission of influenza viruses among
these guinea pigs if you go up to 80%
humidity you don't get transmission
among the guinea pigs so here in the
winter when flu is most prevalent we
have low humidity it's dry and you never
reach 80% humidity here so this could in
fact explain why in temperate climates
like ours there is a prevalence for flu
in the wintertime I also found that
transmission in this model was more
frequent at lower temperatures five
degrees rather than twenty and of course
it's cold and dry here in the humid and
at 30 degrees which is quite warm this
is their centigrade there's no
transmission at all yeah
well here it's probably because the
virus as it's going through the air it's
being desiccated at the high temperature
whereas in the animal even though it's a
higher temperatures kept hydrated okay
so that's a good hypothesis but there
are some confounding factors that I want
to leave you with just to show you that
just because the study tells you one
thing in guinea pigs it doesn't
necessarily apply to the world in
tropical areas some tropical areas
influenza is seasonal now tropical areas
are hot and humid right so why should it
be seasonal if low humidity and low
temperature control the seasonality that
doesn't make any sense in tropical areas
Latin 2009 in April the pandemic swine
origin h1n1 emerged and continued to
spread throughout the spring and the
summer we had flu in July and August of
2009 makes no sense at all totally the
wrong season so the guinea pigs are not
making sense here and so I refer you to
this blog post to read more about it so
it looks like low temperature and
humidity might explain some of the
transmission restricted by weather but
not all of it for sure